hey it's the ktna and this is our song
Summer Never
[Music]
Dies been finding space on my pth to
pain I can't feel it by myself need
inspiration by my
[Music]
side you heard them talk but let them
float right up the window cuz you lost
your head in
honest kindness yeah see they don't know
you they pretend but they ain't done
that much to deserve
to no no
they say they know you but that's a
lie that's a
lie cuz I know exactly what you
do on these late night
D listening to Frankin Miss see
too someone never die
oh all this C in the
sky it falls on my pretty little head oh
pretty little head and you say might got
the
time might got the time but let's just
lay here and
stay lay here and I've been chasing no
wave I can't ignore
no
yeah yeah I so paper clips in my head
last night it felt a little like back to
life reality is just sitting straight I
come and stay in mind you too now you
claim you got something to stay I can't
play I where I've wandered in this
dream I know exactly what you
do on these late night
D listening to franking you SE
too some Never
[Music]
Dies some
never
yeah
oh no no some Never Dies it
oh
no no no some Never
Dies
the No No someone never dies and oh
oh never die oh this C in the
sky I want it to
be all
is
SC
really
oh had it
[Music]
before someone Never
Dies
oh
[Music]